to the big screen film that has Jack
Black and Cate Blanchett showing off
their magic skills only Brooke Anderson
was on the set of the house with a clock
in his wall so creepy in the family film
Jack Black plays a warlock opposite
Kate's witch who takes care of his 10
year old nephew in a creaky old house
with a mysterious tick-tocking heart
three gongs what happens when it gets
down to one nothing good that's for
certain the whole cave of the future the
universe is inside that's that chamber
secrets while giving us a tour of this
incredible set Jack revealed his many
talents and amazing hair and this Jack
tapped his inner rocker for the movie
School of Rock that film is the origin
of a hilarious instagram battle between
Jack and Chris Hemsworth that started
with Jack playfully putting the Thor
actor on blast for stealing this bit
from the hit 2003 film for thor ragnarok
epic battle sequence
and calling you out Thor this is a
challenge I challenge you to a battle
the Battle of the jobs Jack's next move
mocking Thor by posting this perfectly
choreographed slow-motion fight between
him co-star Owen Vacarro director Eli
Roth and Kate from the set your eye you
got me
ah guilty as charged while copping to
the theft not one to back down from a
challenge
Chris responded with this I don't know
what about all the jams isn't our Jam is
jam on toast
I love a bit of that little Pearl Jam
awesome and just general just general
jamming he's actually like a legit funny
dude he totally is not just a hunka
hunka burnin lad my place he goes baby
I'm in
[Music]